Trascrizione: Nicoletta Pedrana
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Diventare genitore, diventare papà,
è un'esperienza meravigliosa.
Quando hai un figlio,
immediatamente pensi al suo futuro,
a quello che potrai fare
per farlo crescere.
Pensi anche ai dettagli,
allo sport che farà,
alla scuola che farà,
al lavoro che riuscirà a fare
quando diventerà grande
e magari farà anche dei nipotini
e ti farà diventare nonno.
Quando ti dicono -
tuo figlio ha solo due anni,
e ti dicono che tuo figlio è autistico,
il futuro non lo immagini più così.
Il futuro diventa nebuloso.
Lo sport non lo immagini, non lo vedi.
La scuola sai che sarà un problema.
Il lavoro sai che non ci sarà,
come non ci saranno i nipotini.
Negli Stati Uniti,
nasce un bambino autistico
ogni 52 bambini;
in Europa ci sono circa
sei milioni di persone con autismo,
un piccolo Stato.
E in Italia?
In Italia ci sono
600.000 persone con autismo.
Provo a ripeterlo, 600.000:
vuol dire un bambino, una persona
ogni 100 persone, ogni 100 italiani.
E malgrado dei numeri così importanti,
per i ragazzi con autismo,
per le persone con autismo
si fa pochissimo.
Pensate alle iniziative
più brillanti in Italia -
e quando dico "brillanti"
intendo veramente luminose,
e non solo in Italia in tutto il mondo.
Forse qualcuno riconosce
la Casa Bianca, in questa immagine.
Il 2 aprile è la Giornata
Mondiale sull'Autismo,
i palazzi delle istituzioni
si illuminano di blu.
Qualcuno ha deciso che il blu
è il colore dell'autismo,
i palazzi delle istituzioni
si illuminano di blu.
Bellissimo, utilissimo per sensibilizzare:
assolutamente niente per far fronte
a tutte le esigenze delle persone
e dei ragazzi con autismo.
Il 3 aprile, passato il blu
di questi bellissimi palazzi,
nelle scuole ancora non ci sono
gli insegnanti di sostegno;
non ci sono il 5 di aprile,
non ci sono il 6 di aprile,
non ci sono il 7 di maggio;
e neanche a giugno,
quando la scuola è finita.
E quei pochi insegnanti
di sostegno che ci sono,
spessissimo non sono preparati.
C'è bisogno di diagnosi precoce.
Mio figlio è stato diagnosticato,
fortunatamente, a due anni:
la diagnosi precoce è fondamentale.
Ma poi, ora che iniziano le terapie,
fa quattro, cinque anni, fa sei anni.
La diagnosi precoce
diventa inutile, in qualche modo:
È meglio che ci sia,
però deve essere precoce davvero.
Le terapie sono a carico,
completamente, delle famiglie.
Il Sistema Sanitario Nazionale,
sull'Autismo, passa poco e niente,
e quel poco ce lo prendiamo tutti,
ce lo prendiamo tutto.
Per esempio, con la mia famiglia,
e per mio figlio,
abbiamo fatto la psicomotricità,
la logopedia e poi l'ippoterapia
e tutto quello che si può fare,
tutto quello che le famiglie,
cercano di fare per i loro figli.
Noi oltre a queste terapie classiche,
abbiamo incominciato a fare la pizza.
Qualcuno ride.
La pizza: mozzarella, pomodoro, basilico.
Il cibo più mangiato dagli italiani,
e anche patrimonio mondiale dell'umanità.
Perché abbiamo iniziato a fare la pizza?
Perché quando hai un bambino autistico,
come è successo a me,
come è successo alla mia famiglia,
tendi a chiuderti.
Un po' ti chiudi,
per proteggere tuo figlio:
perché è difficile,
quando il tuo bimbo incomincia
a sfarfallare in mezzo agli altri,
rimanere sereno;
perché è difficile,
quando tuo figlio incomincia
a saltare senza un motivo,
e vedi gli altri che lo guardano,
rimanere sereno;
perché è difficile,
quando tuo figlio
parla al vento, con nessuno,
usa delle parole a vanvera,
e tu vedi gli altri che ti guardano,
tuo figlio urla,
e le persone ti giudicano
come un pessimo genitore
perché "tuo figlio è maleducato".
Perché i ragazzi autistici
sono dei bei ragazzoni:
non si capisce, vedendoli,
che sono autistici.
Noi perché abbiamo iniziato
a fare la pizza?
Perché con questa scusa
abbiamo incominciato a invitare
tantissime persone a casa nostra.
Con la scusa della pizza,
gli amici venivano a trovarci;
e io e mia moglie potevamo, finalmente,
stare con i nostri amici,
con degli adulti.
Ma venivano anche gli altri bimbi,
venivano i compagni di classe
di mio figlio Leo,
venivano i figli dei nostri amici;
e Leo poteva stare in un ambiente
che conosceva, casa sua,
e fare tutto quello che voleva.
Poteva saltare, poteva giocare,
poteva tirar fuori la sua spada laser.
Leo usa la spada laser
come oggetto per fare amicizia
con gli altri bambini.
Se ne porta sempre in giro due:
una la dà alla persona sconosciuta,
e una se la tiene lui.
In questo modo giocano,
e lui fa amicizia con le altre persone:
si porta l'amicizia da casa.
E oggi l'ha data a me.
Questa mattina me l'ha data,
io gli ho detto che andavo a parlare
con delle persone sconosciute,
e ha detto: Papà, porta la spada laser.
Quindi sono contento che Leo
mi abbia aiutato anche in questo incontro.
Diventa difficile, dicevamo;
ma Leo ha incominciato, un giorno,
a fare la pizza con la sua mamma,
a impastare la pizza.
Sembrava una cosa strana:
e parlandone anche
con delle persone esperte di autismo,
ci hanno detto che
effettivamente è strano,
perché molti ragazzi non amano toccare
gli impasti, la farina, l'acqua.
Tanto è vero che a un certo punto
noi ci siamo detti, con mia moglie:
ma se Leo, che è piccolino,
riesce per gioco a impastare
la pasta, la pizza,
forse anche ragazzi autistici
più grandi lo possono fare,
e così abbiamo invitato a casa nostra
Alessandro, Lorenzo, Gabriele, Lollo,
Matteo, il gigante buono,
una serie di ragazzi in età da lavoro,
grandi, fra i 18 e i 24 anni,
e abbiamo parlato con i loro genitori.
Quello che per noi era un gioco,
abbiamo detto a questi genitori,
potrebbe diventare invece
un'opportunità di futuro.
Quel futuro che non vediamo.
Noi a volte diciamo
che si dice "spettro autistico"
perché diventa un fantasma:
il futuro per noi è un fantasma.
Invece, con la pizza, abbiamo pensato
di potergli dare forma,
non solo quella tonda.
E allora abbiamo incominciato
a organizzare un corso
per fare i pizzaioli,
Anche qui ci dicevano:
ma i ragazzi non ce la faranno mai.
Troppe variabili: per fare la pizza,
ci sono troppe variabili.
Effettivamente, è andata
come ci avevano detto.
Abbiamo iniziato con un gruppo
di dieci ragazzi,
e i primi che hanno messo
le mani dell'impasto
hanno risposto nella maniera
che i libri ci dicevano corretta.
Hanno messo le mani nell'impasto
e... brrr, che schifo.
Molti di loro. Ma non tutti.
Molti di loro ma non tutti.
Per esempio, Alessandro
ha incominciato a fare delle pizze
in maniera meravigliosa.
Il suo insegnante, il suo maestro -
noi lo chiamiamo maestro -
gli ha insegnato
che le pizze vanno schiaffeggiate
dall'interno verso l'esterno,
perché in questo modo
l'ossigeno va nel cornicione.
E il cornicione rimane
più morbido, più buono.
E Alessandro lo fa
in maniera meravigliosa.
Lo stesso maestro, due settimane dopo,
ha spiegato - accidenti per noi, dico -
ha spiegato ad Alessandro
che l'impasto della pizza è una cosa viva.
Perché si fa con il lievito madre,
perché cresce,
perché va fatto riposare per 72 ore.
Bene, Alessandro ha smesso
di fare le pizze.
Adesso alcuni di voi hanno sorriso
perché hanno capito al volo;
noi ci abbiamo messo
due settimane, a capire.
Le cose vive non si schiaffeggiano!
Alessandro; autistico;
interpretazione letterale.
Le cose vive non si schiaffeggiano:
Alessandro ha smesso di fare le pizze.
Gli abbiamo dovuto dire
che deve coccolarle,
e lui ha iniziato a coccolare la pizza.
Noi siamo gli unici al mondo
che fanno la pizza coccolata.
Altro che etica:
rispetto anche per l'impasto!
Alessandro ha imparato a fare le pizze,
e con lui ha imparato a farle Matteo.
Matteo è il gigante buono,
è un ragazzo autistico di due metri.
È enorme, e ha una vocina bianca:
quando parla è uno spasso,
è una meraviglia a vedersi.
Alessandro e Matteo
hanno imparato a fare le pizze,
e allora li abbiamo iscritti
al Campionato Mondiale della Pizza:
700 pizzaioli provenienti
da tutto il mondo:
dal Giappone, dalla Groenlandia,
dall'America, dall'Africa.
700 pizzaioli.
Potevamo iscriverli
a una sezione speciale,
come si fa spesso con le persone disabili.
Certo, avremmo vinto di sicuro:
erano gli unici due pizzaioli disabili!
Uno primo e l'altro secondo.
Abbiamo deciso di iscriverli
con tutti gli altri 700.
Per noi era un gioco, non era una gara.
Bene: in questo gioco,
i due pizzaioli autistici
sono arrivati entrambi nei primi 100.
La pizza coccolata
ha "spaccato", si direbbe.
Ma qual è la cosa importante?
Non è arrivare nei primi 100:
è aver dimostrato che si può fare.
Aver dimostrato che i ragazzi
possono imparare un mestiere,
anche uno di quelli che sui libri
ci viene raccontato che non possono fare
perché hanno un pessimo rapporto
con la farina, l'acqua,
e queste cose che hanno
un'esperienza tattile strana.
Ma per fare un ristorante
servono anche i camerieri:
i pizzaioli non sono sufficienti.
Cosa abbiamo fatto?
I ragazzi che non riuscivano
a lavorare l'impasto,
li abbiamo messi a fare i camerieri.
Abbiamo fatto per loro
un corso di "mise en place".
Io non sapevo neanche cosa fosse,
la "mise en place",
non mi sono mai occupato di ristorazione
prima di "Pizza Aut",
che è il nome di questo ristorante.
Comunque gli abbiamo insegnato
a servire in maniera professionale,
a sparecchiare e apparecchiare
in maniera professionale.
Mentre lo facevamo,
ci siamo accorti di mille difficoltà.
Parliamo di ragazzi autistici:
molti di loro fanno fatica, enorme fatica
a relazionarsi con gli altri.
Molti di loro fanno fatica
a parlare, con gli altri.
Allora abbiamo chiesto
a una multinazionale,
di cui non faccio il nome
per non fare pubblicità,
se poteva costruire per noi una app.
Una app visiva fatta tutta
in comunicazione aumentativa,
tutta per immagini.
In questo modo, attraverso le immagini
i ragazzi prendono le comande
in maniera incredibilmente corretta.
Vanno dalla persona seduta al tavolo,
e con le loro immagini
riconoscono le pizze
e riconoscono gli ingredienti.
E fanno i camerieri: ma lo fanno
come tutti gli altri camerieri.
Certo, la tecnologia li aiuta.
Lo stesso è successo con le pizze,
vi ho raccontato che i ragazzi
sono diventati straordinari
a fare le pizze:
ma quando prendono le pizze con la pala,
e le mettono in forno,
le dimenticano nel forno,
le bruciano tutte.
Perché l'autismo è una brutta bestia:
si girano, fanno le altre,
quella la dimenticano.
Ci siamo inventati - esiste già,
l'abbiamo solo fatto modificare -
un forno a tunnel.
C'è una ruota che gira sempre:
i ragazzi appoggiano
la loro pizza su questa ruota,
la ruota porta l'impasto dentro il forno;
il forno la cuoce;
la stessa ruota lo porta fuori,
e l'altro Cameriere autistico
lo prende e lo porta in sala.
Aprire la mente, aprire il cuore,
aprire i pensieri
ci fa trovare delle soluzioni creative
che costruiscono inclusione.
Pensate: il nove luglio,
proprio per lavorare pienamente
sull'inclusione a 360 gradi,
siamo andati al Senato della Repubblica
a fare le pizze.
È stata un'esperienza incredibile:
qui vedete la conferenza stampa,
a un certo punto Francesco si è alzato
e ne ha dette di tutti i colori
ai giornalisti.
Un'esperienza piacevolissima.
(Risate)
Ma che cosa è successo?
Che i Senatori della Repubblica
hanno capito profondamente
che cos'è l'autismo.
Che cos'è questo spettro,
che ha dimensioni e persone
completamente diverse una dall'altra.
Hanno capito che si possono fare
un sacco di cose.
E con loro stiamo lavorando a una legge
che faciliti l'accesso
nel mondo del lavoro
dei ragazzi autistici.
Una legge che speriamo
non sia solo italiana,
che diventi una legge
che si possa esportare in altri luoghi,
in cui le aziende possano pensare
di assumere delle persone con autismo
non per responsabilità sociale,
non perché sono buone,
ma perché i ragazzi sono,
a tutti gli effetti,
capaci di essere produttivi.
Quando i ragazzi lavorano, diventano
straordinariamente capaci, efficaci,
sale l'autostima
e fanno delle cose incredibili.
Pensate che noi abbiamo fatto
100 serate in giro per l'Italia
in 100 ristoranti diversi.
Dal Veneto alla Calabria,
la Sicilia, le Marche:
ci manca solo la Sardegna,
poi abbiamo girato tutta Italia.
100 serate, abbiamo sfornato 30.000 pizze
e servite 30.000 pizze.
E qualcuno ci diceva
che sarebbe stato impossibile.
In realtà si possono fare davvero
un sacco di cose aprendosi,
ascoltando quello che i ragazzi
sono in grado di fare
e costruendo le situazioni
per poterglielo far fare.
Dopo la visita al Senato,
e il lavoro per costruire il lavoro,
abbiamo pensato che i nostri ragazzi
potessero finalmente assumere
un ruolo diverso nella società:
non più degenti, pazienti,
disabili, handicappati,
ma lavoratori.
Guardate: in questo momento
voi tutti, in sala,
pagate la pensione di invalidità
ai miei ragazzi.
Dal momento che noi assumeremo i ragazzi,
loro pagheranno la vostra, di pensione.
È questa la vera rivoluzione,
è questa l'inclusione vera.
(Applausi)